how about we keep things outside as we
get to explore some of the amazing
experiences that las vegas has to offer
jc fernandez is showing us one of those
experiences
beyond the neon
there's so much to do in the las vegas
territory if you love adventure you can
operate heavy machinery at dig this in
henderson
take a skydiving simulation with flight
gear in a wind tunnel at vegas indoor
skydiving
ride go-karts and play arcade games at
las vegas mini grand prix
or go on an outdoor adventure on your
own atv
russ this is the perfect way to see a
different side of las vegas how many
tours do you guys offer
we offer six different tours we have
three different atv tours
we offer a water sports tour we offer an
off-road race track and we offer an
outdoor
machine gun tour someone's watching
right now they want to ride some atvs
how does the booking process work well
they'll call our reservation line
um here in las vegas make a reservation
we'll set the schedule we'll pick them
up
south end of the strip and then we'll
drive them right out here to uh start
their atv tour
do you guys do some training before they
start sure what we do is uh
we put them on the bike we give them a
full orientation of how the bike works
how it rides the gas the brakes so forth
and then we go through an obstacle
course right here which is right over
here
we get them through the obstacle course
make sure they're comfortable ride and
then we start our tour we have a lead
guy and a trail guide
system along the way how many people can
we do if someone's watching like maybe a
bachelor bachelorette party they got 10
15 friends what's the biggest group we
can do
we typically do up to anywhere from the
max
about 30 people at a time which is a big
group so i brought my own helmet i
actually have my own helmets
okay of course i travel with my own
helmet you provide all the safety gear
for everyone we have all the safety gear
we have helmets and goggles so that's
what we provide for everybody
out here in clubs what do you say we hit
the trail huh sounds good let's do it
all right
russ can i get a little refresher before
we head out sure go ahead and put your
foot on the brake right there
that's back right front brake right
there turn your key right there
put your thumb over there and push that
button shuttle starts up come off
let's go all right let's do it
how amazing is that it is so peaceful up
here
it's a desert oasis looking at looking
at las vegas right now it's incredible
well we're right outside las vegas 20
minutes right next to nellis air force
base and this is the dunes we have out
here that we go on our tours a little
bit of off-road uh trails also again
i've noticed there's some utvs
there's some dirt bikes out here on your
atds i feel so safe yeah they're the
most comfortable and safest bike you can
ride on atvs out here in las vegas let's
stop the talking and go back to right
[Music]
we just got done an incredible one-hour
tour russ how much does the whole thing
cost
134 out the door what's the website las
vegasatv.com
i know you gotta go so i'm gonna
actually do one more round is that cool
go hit it all right
see ya yes jc
all right check out what is open beyond
the neon for more visit
explorer.lasvegasterritory.com
jc is our resident adventure guy yeah
right
he's ready to go has his own helmet he
is down for whatever i love it
good job j.c i